[Music]
hi everybody I'm station su and I'm a
faculty member at the industrial and
systems engineering at USC and today I'm
very pleased to be talking to you about
some of the projects that I've done on
tuberculosis or TB in India so TB now
kills more people than HIV worldwide
which is surprising to a lot of people
and most of my work is focused on India
in the context of Indian tuberculosis
because about a quarter of the world's
cases reside here and besides many of
the drug sensitive or die's cases in TB
one of the problems facing India is a
growing number of drug-resistant
tuberculosis cases of which about three
percent of all cases are so
drug-resistant TB is will happen when
patients undergo antibiotic therapy but
they don't finish their regimens or it
can also occur because of a direct
transmission so I'll talk about both of
those pathways today and the problem
that drug resist drug-resistant or dr TV
presents is really that it requires
treatment with second line antibiotics
which can be more costly and can be more
toxic to the patient and can also be
very difficult to diagnose because these
patients will present with the same
symptoms as a drug sensitive TB patient
so I'm going to talk about some of the
work that I've done in this area
obviously there's a lot of projects here
so I'm not going to talk about all of
them but I welcome questions on any of
them I won't talk about this Gates
Foundation model comparison that I've
done in the past and Ryan here will be
talking a little bit more about the TB
Reese outreach resource allocation model
at towards the end of this talk and care
well introduce some of the topics that
we've been talking about for
collaboration on predicting treatment
default but to move on to some of the
overview of what I've done before I've
one of the bottles that I originally
built was an individual level simulation
on predicting drug resistance t v--
prevalence prediction so in this model
we followed individuals from birth until
death moving through different health
states whether a latent drug sensitive
or drug-resistant TB active disease as
well as treatment and we wanted to make
this model as detailed as possible since
we were modeling indian tuberculosis we
included many of the treatment options
that are available in India such as
private treatment
as well as the one that's offered by the
federal government public treatment for
first line as well as second line
therapy so this is a pretty busy slide
just to guide you through it we looked
at for instance patients undergoing
first-line therapy we looked into the
literature for the RNTCP or the public
funding program that treats tuberculosis
it gives us six months of the treatment
for each patient and there were monthly
risks of death and default that we
incorporated into the simulation so that
we would accurately model how patients
behaved on these treatment programs as
well as things like drug resistant
testing which patients undergo in
first-line therapy at around month four
and they could exit off of treatment
either successfully treated or with
active or latent tuberculosis if they
default or failed from treatment and so
we wanted to be realistic and capture
these patterns as much as possible in
addition we wanted to include
demographic and behavioral factors since
a lot of these things would inform how
tuberculosis is transmitted so for
instance transmission rates varied by
age and reflected household compositions
within the simulation transition rates
depended on Natural History and age and
competing mortality risks also dependent
on age and sex and in the simulation we
had treatment uptake and adherence and
success that varies by age and sex as
well as by the time in what time it was
in the simulation so for instance we had
the model burn in so that our
demographics would stabilize our patient
population that we simulated within the
model would reflect the age
stratifications that we saw in India and
that was very important to get the
population correct and we also had
population growth when the within the
simulation because we know the
demographics within India are changing
over time and so these are matched to
both historical and projections of
Indian population growth for the United
Nations Population division over time we
had the federal treatment program ramped
up and so in the simulation we had more
and more patients have access to
tuberculosis treatment and over this
period and over that time we can see
that the that the simulation estimates
here depicted in red are very similar to
those that were given by the wgo from
this period for both prevalence
and incidents of tuberculosis so we can
be more confident that the simulation is
performing in an accurate way we also
had second line therapy ramp up over the
appropriate period in the simulation so
which now we can do projections about
the future to inform us about how the TB
prevalence in epidemic are going to
behave in the future and over this
period we see secular trends such as
population ageing which we would expect
to see over this period so now we have
this really neat cool simulation what
can we do with it so one of the
interesting things that we could do was
to look at how people acquire
drug-resistant TB and this is a problem
that you can't actually go and ask
people about because people don't know
where they got tuberculosis and so for
these cases of drug-resistant TB which
the government of India is very keen on
reducing we could split them apart and
transmission generated cases which so
people got coughed on and they acquired
drug-resistant TB versus those that were
arising because of failed or incomplete
treatment regimens and we see that over
time
the simulation were projected a larger
and larger proportion of people are
getting cases directly through
transmission and this has implications
for how we can treat drug-resistant TB
and how we can interrupt the process of
people getting these diseases the second
topic I'm going to talk touch a little
bit on is looking at policy
prioritization and looking at
cost-effectiveness analysis to inform
policy decisions so for instance the
government of India is planning to
acquire expensive new gene expert
diagnosis systems which allows for more
accurate TB diagnosis and is also very
quickly able to distinguish between drug
sensitive and drug-resistant
tuberculosis now these are very
expensive systems so we wanted to inform
the government about how they should use
them so one of the ways that we could
use them is to just use them for drug
resistant testing at month number four
and first-line therapy but we can also
introduce these systems for initial
diagnosis so we wanted to look at the
costs and the health impacts of doing
both of these policies and we compared
them against institutional reforms like
public/private mixes or ppm programs
which is the government of India is also
considering doing where private clinic
patients are referred to public clinics
because probably
clinics generally have more oversight
and more informed doctors that are
looking specifically for TB patients we
also looked at combination strategies of
these different policies and by
informing the simulation the individual
level simulation with information about
costs as well as health outcomes we can
form the cost effective frontier for all
of the policies that we considered being
able then to identify the trade-offs
between health and costs and tell the
government where there were inefficient
policies that were not lying on that
effective frontier and so this sort of
analysis can inform public policy in
terms of healthcare the last problem
that I want to touch on is about when to
test for drug-resistant tuberculosis and
this was solved using a pom DP model so
there are two tests that the that is
used for first line therapy sputum smear
tests or SS tests are very cheap but
they're also very inaccurate they hadn't
have very low sensitivity so they're
very noisy and they also cannot detect
the disease strain so these types of
tests which are currently used give us a
very noisy estimate of whether a patient
has TB or not drug sensitive B testing
or DST which we'll consider in the
context of these expensive new gene
expert systems are very expensive as I
told you before but they're very
accurate and it can detect the disease
stream so the question we asked here was
how we could use this noisy test to
identify which patients need DST and
when they should undergo DST so we want
to have high-risk patients and use that
expensive but very accurate test on them
so that we can triage them into the
appropriate second line therapy right
now DST drug sensitive testing is being
done at month four but with this new and
new technology it's unclear whether or
not we should do it earlier or later in
that first line therapy treatment and so
we wanted to define patient specific DST
times that would prevent unnecessary
testing which has high financial costs
but we did want to do it because it
would accelerate triage and appropriate
treatment for those patients that did
have drug-resistant tuberculosis
now recall only about 3% of the TB cases
in India have drug-resistant TB so it's
a pretty low population so we want to
focus on these high-risk patients that
we would be able to identify using this
test so just to give you an overview of
our pom deep
at every month there would be some
belief state that the patient that the
physician had about the patient whether
or not they were successfully treated
whether they still had drug sensitive TB
or had drug-resistant TB they were then
able to do three actions either DST that
patient using that expensive test that's
very accurate or have the patient
continue on treatment either with or
without a noisy test from the sputum
smear test the patient would undergo
treatment and if the physician wanted to
test the patient receive a noisy
positive or negative test result from
the patient and then be able to update
their belief about the patient's health
state so this would continue for the six
months of TB treatment and we ran our
pom DP in order to find the result and
we found that in fact it was optimal to
DST the patient at initial diagnosis
this is somewhat surprising because
there's very few number of TB cases that
have drug-resistant TB and so we would
be unnecessarily testing a lot of people
which has high financial costs now this
is in fact driven by TB transmission
because those downstream costs of
further transmission identifying those
people bringing them into treatment and
then treating them with second light
therapy was so high it was worth it to
do that unnecessary testing upfront so
those are some of the topics that I've
done research on and Brian will now talk
about CB outreach programs and resource
allocation hi everyone so my name is
Brian Wilder and I'll be picking up with
some recent ongoing work on tuberculosis
in India so Z already covered the basic
motivation here and the focus of this
work is how do we get more patients into
treatment for tuberculosis in the first
place because treatment is provided for
free right so this is one of the major
bottlenecks and a common strategy for
this is outreach campaigns right so
patients either don't know tuberculosis
symptoms or they don't know the
treatment is available and so the
government will conduct these
advertising campaigns right to raise
awareness and get people into treatment
when they think that I might have TB
symptoms and so this is just one example
of such an advertisement and there are
many others right and there are many
ways that we could structure these
campaigns so maybe the the out on the
part left here is aimed at parents of
small children the one in the middle is
aimed at sports fans and so on so there
are many different demographic groups
that I can think of advertising to
and I only have a limited amount of
money with which to conduct these
campaigns and so the question that we're
interested in in this work is given that
I have this limited budget how should I
divide it up between different
demographic groups in the population so
who are the sorts of people that I
should focus the most resources on in
order to have the greatest impact on tv'
rates overall so in this work I'll give
a sort of a brief overview so we
introduced an essay a style multi-agent
model of disease spread and then in this
model we give an algorithm called Omo to
compute a near optimal resource
allocation so a division of a finite
budget between different demographic
groups in the population so we're able
to both give theoretical guarantees for
this approach and then we also conduct a
data-driven evaluation and simulation of
the policies produced by our algorithm
and we find that by using its
recommendations compared to an
extrapolation of status quo policies we
can avert thousands of cases of
tuberculosis each year in India so as a
brief overview the style of model that
we have here in this work is it's a
compartmental model so we have different
demographic groups in this case a
segmentation of the population by age
and so there's a finite population of
agents happening these groups they are
born they age they die they move between
groups and so on and so and they also
transmit the disease so there are some
agents that are infected and the agents
in each group have some rate with which
they come into contact with agents and
other groups and if you come into
contact with an infected agent then you
yourself become infected so then when we
think about at optimal targeting of
resources in this model there are a
number of challenges so you might say
well why don't I just target the groups
that have the most infected agents right
that's where all sort of get the most
bang for my buck in terms of targeting
advertisements but this doesn't work on
its own because maybe some groups are
more important for between groups right
right so if there's a particular age
range that's in contact with lots of
others then even if they don't have as
many infected agents insurance the sheer
number maybe you should still focus
advertisements there to reduce
performance rates downstream but that on
its own also is sufficient right because
I would suggest okay maybe I should look
at contact patterns and just immunize or
and just target advertisements that the
groups that have
the most sort of contact with others but
that also is an optimal because you have
to think about the demographics of the
population and how things will evolve
over time as people age and move and so
on then complicating all of this right
these difficulties and what the optimal
strategy might be there's just lots of
things that you don't know about the
problem in practice so in particular for
TV in India we found initial prevalence
rates so the number of infected agents
in each group are really uncertain
because a lot of patients don't report
to approved treatment facilities and we
also don't know these contacts patterns
between the groups right so I don't
really know like what is the rate at
which people who are 20 years old coming
to contact the people who are 40 years
old right these are just things that we
don't really have good data on and so
I'm not going to go into really any
detail about the algorithm here but the
sort of just of it is that we put we
construct an optimization problem sort
of modeling these different trade-offs
and so we answer our approach the demo
algorithm has sort of a principled way
of deciding on the optimal treatment in
a way that accounts for the different
sorts of demographic and epidemiological
factors in the problem and also accounts
for the incompleteness of our data right
so it solves a stochastic problem where
we have only uncertain knowledge so we
only have sort of distributions over
what many of the parameters and the
problem might look at and so we conduct
an evaluation in simulation of the
policy is produced by demo and so we use
existing data from a variety of sources
right so government reports the RNTCP
program the epidemiological literature
and so on and then given that there's
still a lot of uncertainty in the data
then we construct appropriate certain
sort of distributions over the
parameters that we don't know about and
here as a brief snapshot of the results
so we're comparing our algorithm to so
we compared it to a range of different
heuristics and strategies that you could
think of for the problems and there's a
few of them here and so these strategies
are you know what if you just team focus
on the groups with the highest
prevalence rates what if you extrapolate
from the status quo treatment rates
right just focus your resources in
proportion to what's being done now and
lastly what quote high degree so if you
focus on the groups that have the
highest amount of contact with others
and we find that our algorithm
can substantially improve on these
existing sorts of policies and avert
thousands of person hears of
tuberculosis each year compared to these
strategies so this is where we're at
right now with you know a model and
algorithm for targeting TB outreach
campaigns we have promising simulation
results but this is very much an ongoing
project and I hope to talk to if any of
you about work in this area during
breaks thank you any clarification
questions while the next speaker sets up
I at the end of your talk you mentioned
that the doing the DST in the initial
stage is the best does it mean that you
have to do it for every patient or is
there any filter at all you can do to
suspect that someone has that isn't TB
the only information that the physician
had was national prevalence levels so
three percent of the patients would be
drug resistant and everybody else would
be drug sensitive and so we assumed
everybody would be exposed to DST in
that case and it was still
cost-effective to do it so our objective
function there was taking into account
both costs and health outcomes and if
you looked for a long enough time
horizon in fact it was cost saving
because of those save costs from not
having to treat downstream infection